joining me now Ned Ryan founder and CEO
of American majority and Molly Hemingway
Federalist editor-in Chief Fox News
contributor uh we got some other
domestic news we're going to get to but
Ned Biden said moments ago that Israel
is making its own decisions but we know
that's not true don't
we I there's a reason that the the
ground invasion of of Gaza hasn't taken
place and I'm afraid it's it's Biden and
blin and exerting pressure on Netanyahu
to to hold off on that but I think the
other thing too that we're seeing play
out is the incredible weakness you
called them amateurs they are incredibly
weak amateurs uh Biden is weakness
personified but it's his weakness that
has brought us to this place and his
weakness in dealing with Iran his
appeasing of the mulas his giving them
money even more so lifting those
sanctions to give them tens of billions
of dollars more in oil Revenue to fund
Hamas to fund Hezbollah and I I think
the other thing too that's become pretty
apparent to me Lauren watching this this
weakness play out in this specific
situation and then watching those
abhorent comments from the White House
yesterday about anti-Semitism I think
they're in a really difficult Place
politically here at home because the
Rabid left which is the Democratic base
is very anti-semitic is very prop
Palestinian and if they go too hard on
this issue you have the 2024 elections
coming up and if they alienate that
rabid left they're going to go to
Cornell West you lose three or four
points in the Battleground States you've
lost the white house so I think their
weakness has put them in a very awkward
place internationally but it's also put
them in a very awkward place politically
here in this country yeah we're going to
get into a little bit of that later on
with Ed Rollins on the third party
challenges but Molly John Kirby um was
out today and he was asked to grade
Biden's presidency thus far tough
question watch you want me to give him a
you know report card A+ being president
of the United States means balancing an
awful lot of priorities and challenges
whether they're domestic or foreign
president is managing it really really
well because of his long experience in
government the wisdom he brings to the
job the relationships that he has he's
on on top of it
all Molly literally no one on the face
of the planet believes that no one yeah
I don't know if there's anyone in the
Biden Administration I've lost more
respect for than John Kirby uh who is
saying things that are absurd on their
face right there Joe Biden was very
clear that heos osed every single aspect
of President Trump's domestic and
foreign policy he ran on that and we are
now seeing what the fruits of that
opposition is with President Trump you
saw in the Middle East expanding peace
with historic you know the move of the
embassy to Jerusalem with the signing of
the Abraham Accords with things like
when kasm solomani was attacking our
troops we took him out that kind of
strength that you know so it was not a
fear about being strong but you saw
expanding peace in that region with
Biden the Middle East is on fire we have
all of these hostages we have a horrific
situation breaking out that Americans
are going to have to be paying for and
it really is you know just a reminder
that when he said he opposed that
foreign policy and he was elected we are
really suffering from that and Ned
meanwhile in this house speakers race
which you know it's all interrelated but
this house speakers race which is still
going on uh Trump came out against Tom
emmer from Minnesota that killed his
chances of of being the next choice and
he basically wrote on Truth social to
day the Republican party can't take that
chance because that's not where the
America First voters are voting for a
globalist rhino would like Tom emmer
would be a tragic mistake and lo and
behold Emer was out within a seems like
a matter of
minutes yeah that's correct I mean well
emmer it's hard to believe that emmer
was even nominated to be potential
speaker uh he's he's a puke Rhino who
was pushing the national popular vote
which was funded by Soros the fact it's
appalling that he was even considered
for speaker but you know Tom mem was
never going to be speaker Kevin McCarthy
is not going to be speaker by the way
Gates has five votes uh too bad that
that Jordan couldn't persuade some of
those big spending uh Republicans who
want to see the Ukraine gravy train
continue and now you hear rumors that
somehow they might strike someone might
strike a deal with Democrats if you do
that you are definitely a Ben Arnold
you're done but but here's the point but
but the problem more is this some of the
infighting that took place in regards to
who was going to be supporting the 2022
midterms and who was going to get
funding and who was not going to get
funding led to Republicans only having a
four- seat majority instead of a 20-
seat majority and now you're seeing
something play out where you've got
swamp creatures America First more
establishment types fighting each other
I don't see a path for but I will say
this one last thing real quick there are
a lot of people out in the greater world
who say to themselves if there's no
speakers that mean we're not going to
get any more spending that will sell us
out we're totally fine with that in the
short term yeah well I'm not sure how
that's going to work out Molly we're
we're just learning uh moments ago that
there there may be a a deal proposed
where it would be a co-speaker ship with
Jordan and McCarthy Molly is this more
trial balloons that are going to go
nowhere or is that an interesting idea
real quick yeah know it seems like we
are having the conference coming to
terms with how bad the situation is and
I wonder if as as no one is able as the
number of votes keep on getting lower
and lower whether people might try some
kind of strategy like that those are two
people who are broadly liked by the
conference and it might satisfy
different Wings who knows if all the
Republicans stick together they can get
this done but right now it's not done
yet panel thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else